i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales del
programa de france 24 que nos invita a
dar una vuelta al mundo de la mano de
nuestra red de periodistas ha pasado un
año desde el retiro de eeuu de
afganistán y la retoma del poder por
parte de los talibanes un año en el que
los derechos de las mujeres han sido
completamente pisoteados y en el que la
economía del país ha quedado devastada
tras la suspensión de las ayudas
internacionales y el congelamiento de
los activos afganos en el extranjero los
más afectados por esta situación son los
38 millones de ciudadanos que están en
modo de supervivencia según naciones
unidas millones de personas sufren de
malnutrición mientras que la rampante
pobreza obliga a muchos a tomar medidas
desesperadas como vender sus órganos o
incluso vender a sus hijas para
matrimonios forzados el siguiente es un
informe de kathleen oristrell y tarek
kyl
en un barrio pobre en las afueras de
kabul casi 800 familias viven hacinadas
en refugios en ruinas sobreviviendo con
lo poco que tienen
mientras afganistán se hunde cada vez
más en la pobreza algunos aquí están
tomando medidas desgarradoras para
sobrevivir
fátima tuvo que vender uno de sus tres
hijos pequeños
teníamos hambre no teníamos nada para
comer mi hija mayor estuvo internada en
una clínica durante casi dos o tres
meses tuve que enfrentar muchos
problemas esa es la razón por la que
vendía a mi hija
pero sã tiene tres años pero su futuro
está sellado cuando cumpla diez años se
verá obligada a casarse y abandonar el
lugar familiar aún no mi corazón
simplemente no puede aceptar esto cómo
puedo enviar a esta niña de 10 años a
otra casa
por su hija los padres de feroz as
recibieron 150.000 afganis un poco más
de 1600 dólares
fue la decisión más difícil de mi vida
esta fue una decisión muy grande a tomar
en lugar de verlos muertos referiría a
verlos vivos no tuve más remedio que
vender a mi hija
su padre solía trabajar como vendedora
ambulante pero dice que los talibanes
destruyeron su carrito en una represión
contra los vendedores ambulantes sin
licencia y con la economía de afganistán
en crisis muchos luchan por encontrar
trabajo
antes eran jornaleros pero ahora ni
siquiera de sus trabajos existen tenemos
gente que se quiere matar por hambre y
desesperación
algunos vendieron sus opiniones otros
están vendiendo a sus hijos hay tanta
gente enfrentando problemas
al otro lado del callejón nos
encontramos con otra madre en extrema
necesidad su esposo está sin trabajo
ella ya no puede pagar el tratamiento de
su hija discapacitada está vendiendo a
su hermana de 7 años para matrimonio
antes éramos pobres pero ahora la
inflación nos está haciendo mucho daño a
los pobres si no la vendemos qué más
podemos hacer no están en venta pero no
tenemos otra opción zarpó desde el mar
negro el primer barco humanitario
fletado por naciones unidas a bordo
23.000 toneladas de granos destinados a
áfrica el acuerdo mediado por naciones
unidas y por turquía ha dado esperanzas
de poder paliar la crisis alimentaria
mundial que se ha desatado como
consecuencia de la guerra sin embargo
millones de toneladas de cereales aún no
han podido ser exportadas poniendo en
graves dificultades a los agricultores
que no tienen donde almacenar sus nuevas
cosechas pues los silos se encuentran
totalmente llenos informe de melina y ve
a parsons y reid abr 17
dos barcos mercantes se preparan para
salir de odessa cargando soya y maíz la
seguridad es estricta
y ésta sólo es una fracción de las 20
millones de toneladas de productos que
se habían bloqueado desde febrero y eso
sin contar la cosecha de este verano
calcule edición off según cálculos de
nuestro ministerio de economía nos dan
25 millones de toneladas en total
tenemos que exportar 45 millones de
toneladas million trump
ninguna de las opciones ayuda a las
miles de pequeñas y medianas granjas que
rodean el campo
por ahora el único producto que se envía
proviene de los principales productores
agrícolas agricultores como vladimir
están en una larga fila que podría durar
meses o más
los productos
esta es la recolecta del año pasado
trigo invierno alrededor de 60 toneladas
pero no puedo venderlo debido a la
guerra nadie nos está comprando en el
puerto porque todavía están vendiendo
grano el año pasado los graneros están
llenos hay un atasco de registro tienen
que sacar lo que hay primero
vladimir cultiva 300 hectáreas de trigo
maíz y girasol es eso implica costos
importantes está atrapado en un círculo
vicioso
combustible dice el hombre fertilizante
software esto es todo lo que necesitamos
sido baldíos tenemos los trabajadores y
el equipo pero no podemos comprar
combustible porque la cosecha del año
pasado todavía está atascada en las
bodegas
vladimir dice que de dos a tres semanas
cosechar a sus girasoles esto para él es
un momento de celebración y esperanza
pero el resto del año y el futuro sólo
depara incertidumbre y duda algunos
jóvenes que no han sido reclutados por
el ejército de rusia y se rehúsan a
luchar en ucrania han buscado refugio en
moldavia nuestra enviada especial a
chisinau fue al encuentro de dos
desertores que denuncian las campañas de
miedo y desinformación del kremlin para
atraer combatientes a sus filas veamos
el siguiente informe de etel bonet y
diego ibarra
la da empezado una nueva vida llegó hace
dos meses a chisinau donde ha encontrado
un trabajo temporal en un polígono
industrial ha dejado atrás familia y sus
sueños de futuro forma parte de los
jóvenes que no quieren combatir en la de
arrancar nuestro bebé este año iba a
acabar la universidad y quería montar mi
propio negocio de bicicletas llegó una
carta a casa de mis padres pidiendo que
acudiera a una oficina de registro
militar
decidí huir a moldavia
con lo que cobra la edad para pagar una
pequeña habitación en un apartamento
comparativo no sale mucho de casa le
pese a su decisión de haber unido pero
transnistria apoya al bando ruso en la
guerra y si escala tendrá que luchar
contra el cráneo
su abuelo luchó con el ejército
soviético contra los nazis en la segunda
guerra mundial ahora es diferente
por orden de rusia el gobierno nos está
diciendo que tenemos que prepararnos que
el otro lado de la frontera hay un
régimen nazi que quiere desestabilizar
la región están metiendo miedo a la
gente todo es mentira
andrew haya dejado todas sus cosas en su
piso de estudiante de moscú pero se ha
traído su mesa de mezclas no podría
vivir sin sus sesiones de música
experimental llegó hace unos días y se
está quedando en casa de unos amigos en
chisinau
no podía estar más tiempo en moscú la
situación es insoportable cada día se
ven más pintadas en los muros la letra
zeta que significa apoyo a la guerra hay
una fuerte presencia policial en las
calles ya ni siquiera podemos usar las
redes vpn seguras para navegar en
internet o no hay libertad de opinión y
han aumentado las redadas activistas
sean los primeros que quiten eso con
andrew no puede visitar a su familia en
tiráspol porque el ejército de
transnistria lo está buscando para que
se enrolen el ser diferente andray
blatche pertenecen a una minoría
silenciada rusa sus testimonios sirven
para dar luz y no estigmatizar a una
población a la que no se ha preguntado
si quiere la guerra francés se vio
obligada a retomar la lucha contra los
incendios en la región de jong del
suroeste del país la más reciente
conflagración que consumió unas 7 mil
400 hectáreas ya pudo ser controlada
pero para lograrlo los bomberos
franceses requirieron del apoyo colegas
europeos los bomberos alemanes se
unieron a la batalla en la comunidad de
vela vélez informe de nicola frío y
lanzó un pistón y jon emisión
solo unos minutos después de llegar a la
escena de las llamas estos bomberos
alemanes comenzaron a trabajar duro
equipados con bolsas llenas de agua
juntan a los puntos calientes
extinguiendo el fuego antes de que se
extiendan sin embargo para estos
operarios los bosques del suroeste de
francia son un campo de batalla
desconocido the landscape el paisaje las
plantas que crecen aquí los combustibles
que hay son diferentes y las superficies
también se suele quitar la vegetación
circundante a mano para que nada se
encienda es una tarea ardua pero
necesaria la colaboración no es perfecta
todavía
pero he dicho que mientras no tenga un
papel francés que diga que está
permitido no los uso aquí y si un
bombero francés según el equipo la
barrera del idioma puede dificultar el
trabajo del técnico con unas gafas con
hold la obligación como son gp te atrape
prius aiko basten y los demás bomberos
alemanes destacados aquí se ofrecieron
como voluntarios para luchar contra las
llamas para ellos es un acto esencial
firefox kim luz el fondo de volcanes de
vuelos de lentes white topping unos 60
bomberos alemanes están turnando para
trabajar en el incendio pronto se les
unirán más de 300 de otros países
europeos
queremos agradecer a rolo café por
prestarnos sus instalaciones para la
realización de este programa y ustedes
también muchas gracias por seguir un
nuevo episodio de corresponsables nos
damos cita la próxima semana siga con
más información en france 24 y france 24
punto com